my buddy my smile Ong time friend and
Superbowl champion as part of Crown
Royal how are you add better for talking
to you better for talking to you what
are you hearing from Ravens camp these
days Edie how good do you think this
team can be when it's all said and done
it's always that they want to be you
know it's never about it it's never
about anybody else you know if I know
that organization right you know it's
always about the Ravens and how they
play you know I think it's if they work
together in all process of the games you
know all defense often special teams
obviously that's the key to success all
right well I mean they could be all
right or or Flacco it says right you
know from what everybody hearing has
come in as locked in as ever because
love Lamar Jackson's presence and the
last time that he was basically told he
needs to prove himself you guys were in
confetti out of your hair in New Orleans
is that an accurate point that we don't
know minds but uh no I don't think Jude
is coming back focused more just because
of Lamar you know Georgia smart Clara
smart guy he understands that they're
drafting guys every year and at any time
if he's not ready or not performing
right they can take him off the field
you know I think in the last few years
Jo's you know had some injuries you know
and probably not met the expectations
that he's wanted though I know you know
you tend to hear that the grumbles
outside of the organization outside the
team so I'm pretty sure he heard that in
it wants to prove the naysayers wrong
you know being that you know he hasn't
done certain things you know since the
Super Bowl so do you think John Harbaugh
needs to win this year to keep his good
guy knowing the owner as well as you do
and knowing the situation of that
organization as well as you do you know
I went to Houston I want to to the Jets
oh I can't I can't say I know them 100%
I don't
would giant job you know it's a you know
entails this year if he wins for the
playoffs you know I don't know you know
they said Marvin Lewis is gonna lose
this job last year he got an extensive
are you not are you not cool with the
Ravens organization no I'm really cool
with them but I don't get into their
business matters you know as people
think you know fans it hit me all the
time like why are you visiting Atlanta
why are you visiting Cleveland you know
why are you talking to these this team
and that team and not working with us
well the other teams called you know so
I don't know man you know I'm a vocal
guy you know that can rub people some
people the wrong way you know I don't
hold my tongue with football because it
is football you know and we we in a
partnership we working together it
shouldn't be many egos you know though
that's ego especially in coaching for
some reason you know so I don't know man
I can't answer that question too much
from that side of finesse I rich okay so
what do you think of the the talk that's
going down in the Steelers just locker
room right now with Le'Veon Bell holding
out and some of his linemen including
player reps saying that he should be
there that they're disappointed he's not
talking about another player's money
while he is making a business decision
bridge its individual business one thing
I knew about when I got to the league
when the guys doing his business because
I held out my first year when a guy's
doing his business you let him take care
of his business why cuz you know how
brutal this game is you know how
cutthroat this business is you let that
guy handle his business now the selfish
player as we tend to be want our guys
could be there
we want our athletes won our stars to be
there two guys we need to win ultimately
it is about winning and it is a team
sport but like I said it's an individual
business you know so I understand what
the players are coming from but at the
same time they got to answer that
differently let's let those guys let
those guys handle their business you
know their be here when they be here
that's the answer that's the true answer
to this question you know when when when
being asked if that was my teammate
maybe Ron I would love living on to be
here you know any team in the National
Football League would love him to be in
their locker room on their team but he's
trying to take care of business he's
trying to take care of em he's trying to
take care of his body I would recommend
it to him
why because I'm sitting here and I know
the things that don't get done or not
you're not going to get taken care of as
well as you think when you're retired so
you got to make sure that you're
preparing yourself for your future for
paying yourself you know to be taken
care of after the game is over
you know what do you mean by that I'd
get into a little bit more for your
money so if you drink too much at the
game if you over consume you're gonna
pass out you might not be able to
remember the whole game you know so
that's why you take your water breaks
right now I feel like living on and
taking a water break you know because he
understands that he has a lot of plays
that he arm is a part of he's a part of
70% of Pittsburgh's offense
so he's like looking at it like a man
I'm I'm a big part of this I'm not
getting compensated the way I feel I
should be you know as a player not just
a running back but as an NFL player in
the league you know he's probably one if
not two I would say top ten players in
the Football League specially in fantasy
football that people want on a team
because of his production if the
Dutchman speaks for itself
yeah I know you signed the contract but
those contracts are also negotiable you
know so he's got to figure out his
number you know correlated with the
Pittsburgh or Pittsburgh number and they
got to come to an agreement you know
there for both teams are hydrated
properly and they can get this thing
going
no I know and read courtesy of Crown
Royal the water break by the way I just
love the way you're just weaving in your
sponsor into your conversation you are
really next level at read you are next
level I know we'll get to the crown
in a second but I do just want to touch
on this one last piece of business here
when Le'Veon comes in because again he
can't get a long-term deal right now
based on the franchise tag rules right
now so when he comes in how does this
does do the guys just welcome and give
him a hug and then it's all forgotten or
will they just look out of the sides of
their helmets from time to time when
he's coming off the field wondering if
he's coming off the field for a reason
other than a water break what happened
so long as you get there and when you
get there it should be all football it
shouldn't be any business talk because
they not his agent and they're not him
they already got their contract they
already getting a check they worry about
themselves and play football and they
weren't about contract and worrying
about living on and all that stuff
that's going to take away from what
they're trying to accomplish as a team
whenever Le'Veon gets there when he's
obligated to get there journalist under
the franchise tag it's so big you know
because like I said the end of the day
he's got to look out for the betterment
of his business he's a he's a he's a
company within the company you know so I
support the guy and as his teammate sure
though I like I said we're selfish as
players and we want to win especially
when we're there we already got our
contract as coaches and players we want
our best guy to be there we want him to
get in but at the same time we also
should understand that other side of
things what do you think of the new
helmet rule every rich yeah you know I
was one of the first to be suspended
with the helmet rule you know football
is a violent sport it's gonna it's going
to be that way for ages it's always been
that way for hundreds of years you know
arm is built off violence so to say you
know it's a reflection of this country
the NFL is the reason why a lot of
things whatever but anyway the helmet
rule you know it's tough rich because
football is an instinctive sport very
extincted sport guys training all
offseason
to better their instinct you know and if
they study film like I did you know
they're going to get there faster than
most guys and it could be a collision or
they can make a play
preferably an interception from my
perspective but I'm just saying you know
it's a very extincted sport those guys
are training to get their first rich all
all season their training um during the
week to get their first two separate guy
from the ball to break up a pass so
there's going to be so many bang-bang
play so many quick plays that happen
it's just we have the technology now we
have enough people watching the game
I've been sitting with random fans
that's watching the game it's something
happens and they can make the call right
then and there but we take it to new
york and it takes 10 minutes or so you
know last year any way to make a call
when we've already really saw it whether
it was vicious if you tried you could
see if a guy tried to do something you
know we have the luxury in this country
to see that you know so I just don't
think we utilizing our technology right
you know we need we need the technology
they have at the US Open man I mean they
seen the ball hit the line you know I
know we could we should better use all
that you know so I don't think we don't
we hold back stuff you know we hold back
stuff and and not utilize the things
that we have just to make the game right
well and and retie right call and read I
appreciate you coming on part of the
water break a movement encouraging
responsible game day consumption
reinforcing the importance of drinking
in moderation and hydrating between
alcoholic beverages you are the man at
Reid let's do this more often okay you
know to make you know make sure people
taking their water breaks you know a
drink irresponsible you know drinking in
moderation making sure they taking water
breaks and not over consume alcoholic
beverages that way they can enjoy the
game and really yell for their team
you're drunk you can't yell for your
team
nobody's know what you're yelling you
tend to want to curse your own players
out and what upsets players don't like
that you know a drunk fan behind the
bench cursing their own team out you
know so we don't want anybody in over
arms should I say sir I served over
served thank you too much you know we
want them drinking in moderation we want
them taking a good water break
drinking responsibility hydrating
generously you know to make sure that
they can enjoy the game and enjoy the
people that they with you know and get
home safely and take care of yourself
we'll chat soon right back at 20 right
back at you at 20 er on Twitter the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience